Hello and welcome to this video on the Environmental Query System.
In this we're going to be doing a little bit of theory about the system and then we are going to
be jumping in and building one inside the project. So to start off with, what is the
Environmental Query System? Well, this is a system much like the Perception System, but
where the Perception System is reactive to what is going on around it in the world,
the Environmental Query System is proactive and it allows us to make more complicated
assessments of the environment. For example, if you wanted to find a hiding spot or maybe a spot
where you had a sniper or something that wanted a bit of cover so that it could have a good view
of shooting of things, then the Environmental Query System is what you would use. You would go
away and analyze the environment and then score it and filter them based on your tests and return
you some places which are of use to you. Now each Environmental Query goes through four stages.
So the first stage it goes through is it generates. Now you start off by generating a
number of points that you want to check out. There's a number of different ways to generate
these starting points. Do them in a grid, a circle, you can just grab specific actors.
So there's a ton of different ways to generate these points. And then after that, what we do is
we have a number of different tests that you can set up. And you can set up a whole load of
tests and the tests will be automatically in the back end of the system. They'll be
arranged into a sensible order. First of all, it will do any filtering that is required.
So this is where once we've generated the points, we can eliminate points entirely based on what you
want for your test. So for example, you could eliminate any points that were too far away or
that had line of sight from a specific area. And after you've filtered out all of those spots,
it will then go on to scoring the different spots. And this is where based on your tests,
you assign a value to each spot. Now be positive or negative. But once you've done that,
you're then going to go away and select either one spot or multiple spots. Usually,
and in our test, we're just going to be returning one spot. So for example,
you might be returning the best hiding spot under your restrictions. And then you can either
move to it or you can do some action based off of that. There are two core classes,
which I would like to cover. Now we have the Environmental Query itself.
This is the group of tests that we're looking at doing. So the generation of points and the
group of tests. In our case, we're going to be finding good hiding spots, but it could be
anything where you want to query the environment. The next one is the Environment Query Context.
Now, in order for us to do tests, we need to provide them with context for what the
test will be around. And there are a couple of pre-made contexts which are in the system.
For example, the AI itself can be a context, the point itself. So if you want to test if you
can see the point from the AI, those are the main two which are built into the system.
If you want different contexts from this, you're going to need to write a small bit of code to
create those contexts. Another class that we haven't touched on, and this isn't actually used
in the game, but it's fantastic for setting up your tests and checking that they're working
correctly, is the EQS testing war. Now this is a class that you can place into the level
and this will, while it is selected, it will visualize all of the points that we have created
and the results of their tests. You'll see here that they have different colours and they have
different numbers attached to them. So first we'll talk about the blue points. Now the blue
points are eliminated. So these are ones that are filtered out so that no tests are continually
done on. Now you'll notice that next to each of them they have the name and a happy number.
So you can see at this point we have distance and it's zero. So this means that these have been
eliminated by a distance test and it was zero in the execution channel. Execution chain order
isn't going to be the same as the order that you place the tests in because the system under
the hood will start off with the cheaper tests. For example you could eliminate using a trace
or a distance. However distance is considerably cheaper than trace. Therefore we will first
run the distance check even if it is the last in the order and we will filter out those
so we don't need to do the expensive trace test. You can cycle through this. You can change
the number on the EQS horn so that you can see just tests one through to whatever number it is.
I think we'll demonstrate that in the engine. However we can also see that there are a number
of points that just have a value. Now the value will be some value it's usually between zero and
one but it can go higher and lower depending on how you set them up. But what these are going to
be doing is they are a scoring value. So the results of the test they will get a value from
them. Red will indicate that you are at the low end of the gradient of the score.
Green will be at the higher end of the score. So in this case again this is looking at distance
so the spots that are closer to the EQS testing horn will be in green and the ones that are
further away will be red. And this is useful because when we ask for it to select us a point
we'll either select the best point so that has the highest value or in the top five percent
if we want to add the level of randomness to it. So those are how these points are displayed.
The values are the total value of the entire test. Now that brings us to the end of the
theory for EQS. After this we will be setting one up in the project in Maxercise.